bonjour Sophie prima merci beaucoup
d'être notre invité ce matin pendant
cette première demi-heure vous êtes élus
des Yvelines bon du groupe les
républicains et vous préciser la
commission des affaires économiques du
Sénat on va parler du texte dont vous
êtes la rapporteur sur la compétitivité
de l'agriculture française mais d'abord
l'actualité c'est donc cette interview
hier soir d'Emmanuel Macron et cette
phrase sur la réforme des retraites
qu'il a défendu et qui l'assume mais
cette phrase qu'on a entendu dans le
journal cette réforme comme elle est
impopulaire tout le monde s'est débimé
comment vous réagissez à cette phrase
alors que la droite sénatoriale a
soutenu assez mal en fait assez mal
parce que une fois de plus la droite
sénatoriale je trouve dans cette phrase
étant globée donc alors que je dirais
que c'est plutôt le gouvernement qui se
débigne depuis quatre ans c'est une loi
impopulaire comme vous l'avez dites que
nous assumons au Sénat à chaque projet
de loi de finances de la sécurité
sociale et dont nous montrons la voie au
gouvernement de depuis quatre ans et je
crois que le Sénat n'a pas manqué sur
cette loi des retraites ce projet de loi
des retraites nous avons beaucoup
discuté le président du Sénat c'est
beaucoup investi les groupes politiques
se sont beaucoup investis dans une
discussion dans un vote que pour lequel
nous sommes allés jusqu'au bout
avec évidemment des exigences maintenant
qui vont aussi arriver sur la loi
travail pour rééquilibrer un certain
nombre de déséquilibres qui ont été
discutés mais nous avons été là donc je
le prends assez mal et je trouve que
c'est une énième provocation du
président de la République à l'égard de
ceux qui ont plutôt l'intérêt du pays en
tête voilà je le prends assez mal alors
que le gouvernement cherche à travailler
avec les républicains alors que le
gouvernement cherche à travailler du
coup alors que la droite républicaine a
toujours en ligne de mire l'intérêt du
pays dans tous les textes que nous
examinons et d'ailleurs on en parlait
tout à l'heure en off moi comme
présidente de la commission des affaires
économiques sur 12 ou 13 commissions mix
paritaires dans lequel on a travaillé
sur des sujets économiques et bien nous
nous sommes mis d'accord dans
dans 12 cas 12 cas sur 13 donc j'estime
que voilà je fais porter la voix du
Sénat mais je fais aussi porter
l'intérêt de la France et je soutiens un
certain nombre de réformes donc je
prends assez mal cette cette phrase le
gouvernement qui est dans une grande
séquence réindustrialisation va parler
du projet de loi industrie verte dans
quelques instants mais hier il y avait
le sommet de Schulz France dans votre
département
reçu par Emmanuel Macron 13 milliards
d'investissements c'est un record 8000
emplois directs à la clé il réussissent
parit de la réindustrialisation de chef
de l'État mais il faut réussir ce pari
de la réindustrialisation parce que pour
le moment l'industrie est encore très
end de ça d'abord de ce qu'elle a été
évidemment dans les années 70 75 80 etc
mais même de son niveau de performance
avant la période du covid donc il faut
évidemment accélérer l'industrialisation
il faut permettre à l'industrie de
participer à l'effort de décarbonation
de notre économie il faut ré-irriguer le
pays et tous les territoires donc oui il
faut aller dans cette direction et la
aussi je serai évidemment
dans cette lignée de réindustrialisation
de la France il faut le faire quelque
chose sa politique volontariste en la
matière oui il y a une politique
volontariste qu'on peut pas dénier il y
a une politique aussi de l'Europe mais
nous ne sommes pas les seuls dans la
course j'entends qu'on est effectivement
le pays où les investissements étrangers
sont les plus importants mais il y a
quand même cette certains secteurs
d'activité sur lequel on a du mal à
démarrer voyez on parle des usines de
composants qui vont s'installer c'est
une très très bonne nouvelle mais
l'Allemagne a pris le leadership de de
des composants depuis un petit moment
déjà et elle délivre déjà donc il faut
il faut que nous accéléions donc cette
loi par exemple industrie verte et la
bienvenue pour permettre l'accélération
sur des fois des procédures qui sont
trop longues en France donc a priori
vous la soutenez cette langue on va
regarder ce qu'il y a exactement à
l'intérieur et on va permettre
l'accélération qui est bienvenu on est
dans l'accélération des procédures vous
savez c'est le mal du pays on a fait la
même chose avec l'installation centrale
nucléaire on va faire la même chose avec
avec l'industrie ça avait commencé
d'ailleurs aucun Keny précédent avec une
une loi qu'on avait dit gazbariant du
nom du de l'actuel président de la
commission des affaires économiques de
l'Assemblée il faut aller vers
l'accélération oui on va parler du texte
dont vous êtes la rapporteur qui est
examiné au Sénat sur la compétitivité de
l'agriculture française on regarde
d'abord les détails de ce texte avec
notre journaliste parlementaire Alex
Pusa
[Musique]
le Sénat et va donc d'une proposition là
pour la compétitivité de l'agriculture
française est-ce que ça veut dire que
notre agriculture est en déclin alors
rien déjà on peut dire que la France est
toujours une puissance agricole sa
production en 2022 s'élève à 95
milliards d'euros on est au premier rang
européen devant l'Allemagne devant
l'Italie au 5e rang mondial alors sur le
papier cela paraît très bien mais c'est
moins bien qu'avant car il y a 20 ans la
France occupé le deuxième rang mondial
en terme d'agriculture et au fil des
années notre agriculture décline un peu
et elle est importation de produits
étrangers augmentent dans la
consommation des Français selon un
rapport du Sénat sur le sujet en 2021 en
France un pôle est sur deux était
importé plus de la moitié de la viande
hauvine consommée était également
importé tout comme 28% des légumes 71%
des fruits il y a donc une inquiétude
sur la capacité de la France à nourrir
sa population et pour le sénateur
Laurent Duplomb c'est interdépublicains
à l'origine de cette position de loi et
bien cette perte de vitesse de la ferme
France s'explique par un manque de
compétitivité une perte de compétitivité
par rapport aux autres pays on va
l'écouter le déclin de notre agriculture
est expliqué à 70% par nos manques de
compétitivité à travers plein de points
des charges trop importantes une sur
transposition entre importante un état
pas suffisamment protecteur une un
climat médiatico-politique qui est à
charge et qui vivitande sans cesse le
modèle agricole et des agriculteurs qui
ne savent plus qui ne savent plus à quel
saint se vouer et puis précisément ce
manque de compétitivité de l'agriculture
française elle s'explique selon certains
sénateurs par des normes
environnementales trop strictes avec des
agriculteurs qui se retrouvent sans
solution écouter le sénateur Henri
Cabanel notre pays on a interdit pas mal
de produits phytosanitaires qui
handicapent donc les producteurs sans
pouvoir arriver à mettre en place des
produits de substitution on peut parler
éventuellement donc du
10 métaux hâte sur la cerise qui a à
bénéficier donc à une importation
massive de cerise au détriment dans des
producteurs français et là et
effectivement il faut travailler
toujours quand on veut supprimer un
produit d'avoir un produit de
substitution qui permettent de continuer
l'exploitation
et avec ce texte il vise donc à relancer
la compétitivité de l'agriculture avec
toute une série de mesures lesquelles
alors ces mesures elles sont issues des
travaux de sénateurs de la commission
des affaires économiques du Sénat et on
peut en retenir quelques-unes d'abord
l'arrêt de la surtransposition des
normes européennes qu'est-ce que c'est
la surtransposition et bien c'est quand
la France décide d'imposer une norme à
ces agriculteurs qui est plus stricte
que la norme européenne et cela crée un
désavantage concurrentiel avec les
productions d'autres pays européens ce
texte sénatorial propose aussi de créer
un livret d'épargne agriculture pour
financer les investissements agricoles
et resserrer le lien entre les Français
et leur agriculture cette proposition
loi elle exclut également l'agriculture
du bonus malus mise en place sur les
contrats courts car ce serait un système
qui pénaliserait notamment les filières
de production qui travaillent avec des
employés des employés saisonniers et
puis enfin ce texte prévoit la création
d'un haut-commissaire à la compétitivité
agricole qui aurait pour mission de
centraliser de faire remonter les
différentes difficultés des filières
agricoles Sophie frima d'abord pour
commencer vous diriez qu'aujourd'hui
l'agriculture française est en déclin
oui bien sûr l'agriculture française
perd des positions au niveau européen
mais plus inquiétant c'est
qu'aujourd'hui notre balance commerciale
qu'on vous retirez les vins est
aujourd'hui négative ce qui en France
est un traumatisme extrêmement important
puisque nous étions exportateurs de
denrées alimentaires mais plus encore
comme l'a montré différents rapports
celui du plomb il y a du sénateur du
plomb pardon de leur Duplomb il y a
trois ans et puis le dernier que nous
avons fait l'année dernière nous voyons
que nous perdons des positions et
surtout que nous importons de plus en
plus et la préoccupation elle est là
nous importons d'ailleurs du point de
vue intra-européen c'est à dire que nous
sommes en compétition même avec des pays
en Europe dans le marché intérieur qui
deviennent plus performants que nous et
qui nous de le marché français au
détriment de notre production nous ne
sommes pas assez confort en matière de
compétitivité comment vous l'expliquez
qu'on soit moins performant que nos
voisins européens on s'impose trop de
normes environnementales on s'est imposé
dans les 10 15 dernières années et
surtout une répétition de normes j'ai en
tête par exemple les histoires de cage
pour les poulets évidemment le bien-être
animal est une préoccupation et je pense
qu'en France nous faisons des efforts
pour aller dans le sens du bien-être
animal et donc petit à petit il y a des
lois une première loi qui va augmenter
le la taille des cages et puis peut-être
quatre ans ou 5 ans après on va les
réaugmenter et puis ensuite on va aller
vers le plein air mais tout ça ça
demande des investissements aux
agriculteurs qui font des
investissements majeurs pour changer
leur pour poulailler pour aller plus
dans le sens du bien-être animal mais
ils ont même pas le temps d'amortir
leurs investissements qu'on leur demande
de nouveaux investissements donc vous
voyez c'est un exemple parmi d'autres
mais qui illustre de façon claire la
façon dont la force d'être trop exigeant
en fait on décourage on perd de la
compétitivité on va à l'encontre en fait
des objectifs que l'on que l'on poursuit
est-ce que du coup Emmanuel Macron a eu
raison je dis de demander une pause dans
les normes européennes en matière d'en
moi je pense que c'est pas une histoire
de pause je pense que être exigeant
vis-à-vis de l'environnement vis-à-vis
du bien-être animal en ce qui concerne
c'est une exigence de tous les jours
simplement il faut toujours faire une
balance entre la compétitivité la
durabilité de de notre agriculture et et
la compétition intra-européenne quand on
mène aux agriculteurs dans des
situations de concurrence déloyale
vis-à-vis de leurs collègues européens
et bien je pense qu'on ne rend pas
service à l'agriculture et du coup qu'on
ne rend pas service à l'environnement
parce que nous sommes très exigeants il
faut assurer et assumer ce statut mais
il faut pas mettre nos agriculteurs en
situation de concurrence déloyale
justement sur ce sujet actuellement le
ministre de l'Agriculture remet un peu
en question l'interdiction par notre
agence nationale sanitaire lances d'un
herbicide le S métola chlore c'est une
décision qui a été publiée par l'ancêtre
et le ministre de la Culture dit il faut
qu'on attende les décisions des agences
européennes pour ne pas créer de
justement de distorsion de concurrence
vous êtes d'accord il faut mettre en
question la décision d'une agence
sanitaire nationale alors en fait dans
la loi d'avenir en 2016 à l'époque le
ministre de l'Agriculture monsieur le
folle avait transféré la responsabilité
des autorisations de mise sur le marché
du ministère de la Culture vers notre
agence notre agence elle est excellente
c'est une des meilleures au monde la ne
cesse c'est une des meilleures
européennes et d'ailleurs quand les
industriels doivent déposer des
autorisations ils vont de mise sur le
marché ils vont dans notre agence
française elle est vraiment très bonne
la difficulté c'est que maintenant on a
qu'une décision qui est prise d'un point
de vue scientifique et c'est très
important de évidemment regarder
l'impact sanitaire et l'impact sur
l'environnement mais il faut faire une
balance bénéficerie quand vous comme
individu vous prenez un médicament vous
avez une notice qui vous dit attention
il peut y avoir des effets secondaires
et pourtant vous décidez votre médecin
il décide de vous donner le médicament
parce que il y a un bénéfice qui est
supérieur au risque et bien cette
analyse bénéfice risque elle doit être
faite aujourd'hui sur des molécules qui
posent des problèmes par le ministère de
l'Agriculture et mettre dans la balance
une analyse bénéficier risque entre les
risques sanitaires qui sont données par
l'agence et puis et puis les bénéfices
ou en tout cas les positions de
concurrence loyales ou des loyales et
puis elle doit aller en Europe l'ancêtre
pour faire valider ses propres résultats
au niveau européen
une question sur le plan o Sophie prima
qui va aussi s'imposer aux agriculteurs
le ministre de la Culture l'a dit ils
vont aussi devoir faire des efforts pour
diminuer leur utilisation de la
ressource en eau est-ce que vous
craignez que ça fragilise encore plus la
production agricole mais l'eau c'est un
élément de compétitivité comme d'autres
outils de production si je veux dire
mais c'est à cette faculté particulière
en tout cas cette caractéristique
particulière d'être multi-usage l'eau
c'est un bien que l'on utilise pour
beaucoup de choses il faut donc prôner
la sobriété pour ça il faut prener
probablement une réflexion dans les
bassins dans chacun des bassins
territoriaux où se trouve l'eau et de
réfléchir ensemble à quel usage quelle
priorité et quelle mécanique est-ce
qu'on doit la stocker pendant l'hiver on
voit qu'on vendait en ce moment ça
déborde des nappes phréatiques des bords
et on se dit ben voilà si on la garde
aujourd'hui c'est eux qui déborde et qui
retournent à la mer et bien peut-être
qu'on pourra l'utiliser à des moments
qui seront plus favorables donc oui il
faut avoir une réflexion raisonnée
apaisée autour de l'utilisation de l'eau
il faut le faire par bassin c'est très
important que les agriculteurs aient
accès à l'eau parce que sans eau il n'y
a pas d'agriculture votre texte il fait
pas vraiment l'unanimité ni auprès des
associations de consommateurs ni auprès
des sénateurs les socialistes ont dit
que votre compte les écologistes se
disent sidérés devant tendre ton en
arrière qu'est-ce que vous répondez je
pense qu'il ne faut pas caricaturer les
éléments de ce texte il me semble que
nous parlons de compétitivité quand nous
avons parlé de durabilité et d'éléments
environnementaux depuis maintenant 10-12
ans on a poussé les feux vraiment très
très loin sur ces éléments là et on n'a
jamais parlé de compétitivité
aujourd'hui notre texte il vise à
rééquilibrer en fait ce discours sur le
même principe tout à l'heure que le
bénéfice risque je veux dire on peut pas
parler de durabilité de l'agriculture si
on parle pas de compétitivité et on le
voit bien par l'augmentation des
importations qui touchent aujourd'hui
notre pays donc il faut pas opposer la
durabilité l'environnement
avec la compétitivité je crois que c'est
vraiment une erreur il faut pas se poser
dans des dogmes voilà alors je pense
qu'il y a quelques articles qui font un
petit peu bondir les écologistes parce
qu'il considérait que ce sont des
avancées spectaculaires moi je ne vois
aucune avancée spectaculaire et aucun
résultat oui en 2011 j'ai fait un
rapport avec Joël Labbé écologiste sur
l'utilisation des produits phytos et
dans ce rapport il y avait une
préconisation qui disait alors moi
j'étais moyennement d'accord mais bon
dans globale du du rapport on l'avait
votée qui était la séparation vente
conseil entre les produits phyteux pour
les produits phytosanitaires qu'est-ce
qu'on voit quelques années plus tard on
voit que ça ne marche pas on voit que ça
ne marche pas parce que les agriculteurs
se retrouvent tout seul en réalité sur
leur exploitation et qu'en réalité ils
sont perdus et quand on est perdu et
qu'on n'est pas suffisamment formé et
ben on peut faire des choses qui sont
pas les meilleures du monde et en tout
cas ça les éloigne en fait des progrès
que font aussi les entreprises de
phytosanitaires y compris celles qui
font des produits et des qui offrent des
solutions biologiques donc c'est ça
qu'on veut corriger dans ce texte il
faut pas le caricaturer et pas opposé
durabilité et compétitivité dans
l'actualité en matière agricole il y a
ces propos de Michel-Edouard Leclerc qui
font réagir ils menace d'importer des
produits manches moins chers venant
d'Espagne ou du Portugal il veut pouvoir
aller chercher en Europe les prix les
plus bas il appelle pour cela un
changement de la loi qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez
il demande un changement de la loi bon
alors d'abord il nourrissent ce que je
viens de dire c'est à dire que si on
n'avait pas de problème de compétitivité
de notre agriculture il irait pas
chercher des
produits à l'étranger donc en quelque
sorte je le remercie d'avoir dit ça pour
pour renforcer voilà les travaux qu'on
fait sur la compétitivité ensuite Michel
Édouard Leclerc il donne dans la
provocation évidemment
comme d'habitude j'allais dire moi je
suis très très attentive effectivement
au phénomène d'inflation qu'il y a sur
les produits alimentaires et et les
produits qui sont faits par nos
industries agroalimentaires
néanmoins il faut quand même se mettre
en tête que on reviendra pas au prix
d'avant on reviendra pas au prix d'avant
parce que en dehors des épices
phénomènes de variations des prix il y a
la loi égaline et qui dit quoi la loi
agalim qu'elle veut rémunérer les
agriculteurs au juste prix et les
industries agroalimentaires au juste
prix et donc il y a une partie de cette
inflexion qui trouve qui trouve sa
racine dans la loi égalime et qui est
une loi qui protège la rentabilité des
agriculations tout le monde joue le
maire doit recevoir les industriels
demain il appelle à une réouverture des
discussions entre mercure les
réouverture elles sont prévues dans la
loi donc les agriculteurs
et les distributeurs peuvent se remettre
autour de la table c'est prévu donc les
choses sont prévues dans la loi moi
j'appelle
mais tout le monde joue le jeu je ne
sais pas si tout le monde joue le jeu
mais tout le monde les distributeurs
n'ont pas joué le jeu non plus
totalement quand les prix de
l'alimentaire des produits agricoles
mais aussi du transport de l'emballage
etc
pour augmenter je pense qu'une partie
des hausses n'a pas été prise en compte
donc voilà c'est la négociation c'est de
la communication de Michel-Edouard
Leclerc d'ailleurs j'observe que ça lui
ça fonctionne bien parce que c'est part
de marché vont très très bien et donc
j'observe aussi que c'est lui qui fait
les efforts et qui peut donc les faire
merci Alex merci beaucoup à tout à
l'heure parler de la prévention des feux
de forêt ce sera à suivre effectivement
ce sera le débat du club on va voir
l'actualité dans votre département des
Yvelines maintenant Sophie prima avec
nos partenaires de la presse régionale
on va retrouver Sébastien Couratin
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
Sébastien journaliste à l'écho
républicain Sébastien vous avez présenté
ce week-end dans votre journal les trois
sites qui accueilleront des compétitions
cyclistes dans les Yvelines pour les
Jeux Olympiques de 2024
et en effet le sud des idées n'est
particulièrement bien loti pour ses JO
de Paris on est cyclisme de BMX de VTT
et sur piste trois disciplines ou des
Français en l'habitude de briller avec
de vrais promesses de médailles alors la
semaine dernière la Fédération française
de cyclisme a présenté aux athlètes la
nouvelle piste couverte de BMX au
Stadium de 51 en Yvelines c'est un 400
m² qui a coûté 10 millions d'euros mais
ça on valait la peine si on en croit les
pilotes qui l'ont testé ce week-end leur
verdict exigeante mais parfaite pour la
compétition avec quelques maîtres
l'anneau de vitesse du vélo de route de
Saint-Quentin accueillera les épreuves
sur piste quant aux épreuves de VTT
elles auront lieu sur la colline
artificielle d'Élancourt à quelques
kilomètres de là alors ce triptyque
cycliste complète à la belle dotation
olympique du département qui hébergera
également le pentathlon moderne et
d'équitation à Versailles ou encore le
golf aiguillancourt madame la sénatrice
qu'elle retombait quelle visibilité
attendez-vous de ces JO pour votre
département
accueillir les choses olympiques c'est
évidemment une grande fierté c'est aussi
l'occasion de faire des investissements
que vous venez de mentionner et
d'utiliser des investissements passés
qui sont très très importants dans les
Yvelines nous avons les Yvelines sont un
département de vélo le président du
Département est très très attaché à ce
sport qui est un sport à la fois
populaire jeune dans ses expressions je
pense au VTT au BMX etc donc il est très
très attaché on a le Tour de France qui
passe pratiquement chaque année c'est le
départ du Paris-Nice il y a des gros
gros investissements évidemment le
vélodrome de Saint-Quentin on est un
exemple c'est donc quelque chose pour le
département des Yvelines qui est
consubstantielle à sa politique sportive
donc nous nous accueillons 100 ans après
parce que les Jeux olympiques sont venus
dans les Yvelines en 1924 donc on est
très très fiers d'accueillir pour se
centenaire de nouvelles de nouvelles
installations et de nouvelles épreuves
c'est évidemment une visibilité pour
notre territoire qui est très importante
d'un point de vue sportif je l'ai dit
mais aussi d'un point de vue touristique
moi j'adore les les images du Tour de
France qui passent dans les Yvelines on
y voit la vallée de Chevreuse on y voit
voilà la vallée de la Seine et tous nos
espaces forestiers agricoles naturels
dont on peut jouer donc c'est un fort
formidable vitrine devant le monde
entier pour notre pour notre département
que le marathon passe devant le château
de Versailles que l'équitation soit au
bout de l'allée du roi ça va être
vraiment formidable il y a une polémique
vous la voyez sur le prix des billets de
ces Jeux Olympiques qui sont des prix
exorbitants jusqu'à 2700 euros pour la
cérémonie d'ouverture est-ce que vous
appelez à des jeux plus populaires oui
j'appelle à des jeux plus populaires
évidemment je crois que l'accessibilité
au plus modeste enfin chacun des
Français est une clé de la réussite des
Jeux Olympiques bien sûr il y aura
l'héritage des infrastructures bien sûr
il y a la promotion de notre territoire
mais c'est un moment qui doit être
partagé par le plus grand nombre d'entre
nous et j'espère qu'on aura la sagesse
voilà d'accueillir le plus grand nombre
et la plus grande diversité de
population et Dieu sait si dans les
Yvelines on a une diversité de
population très très large
dans notre sujet avec vous Sébastien
puisque vous avez également évoqué dans
vos colonnes c'était la semaine dernière
le discours du 8 mai prononcé par le
maire de Chartres et rédigé à l'aide
d'une intelligence artificielle
en effet le maire de Chartres a été l'un
des premiers sinon le premier à
reconnaître publiquement avoir rédigé un
discours officiel à l'aide de
l'intelligence artificielle chat GPT et
il l'assume pour lui il y a une
technologie d'avenir avec leur d'égalité
des chances le discours qui est la
prononcé c'était le pour le 8 mai on est
selon lui illustration alors certes la
copie de l'élève robotiques n'est pas
parfaite le maire relève des lourdeurs
des répétitions mais l'outil à tout de
même inclure des spécificités qui le
rendent conformes à ses yeux à ce qu'il
attendait il explique que les clients il
n'est pas nécessaire d'avoir fait de
longues études il suffit de savoir lire
écrire compter qu'ensuite l'outil donne
la priorité au talent à la réflexion à
la valeur ajoutée l'élu précise même un
brin provocateur qu'il vaut mieux passer
une journée sur Chat GPT qu'un mois avec
un instituteur à la sortie vous
l'imaginez a susciter des foudres de
l'opposition à Chartres a fait le buzz
sur les réseaux sociaux alors
aujourd'hui le maire il souhaite passer
à la vitesse supérieure en injectant de
l'IA au cœur des pratiques de sa
connectivité la ville de Chartres pour
rédiger par exemple des contenus
administratifs est libéré ainsi du temps
aux agents vous madame la sénatrice
est-ce que vous imaginez utiliser un
jour dans le cadre de vos activités
parlementaires Unia par exemple
en tout cas Jean-Pierre gorge qui est
toujours très avide de technologie et de
nouveautés donc voilà il fait le buzz
avec ça c'est intéressant en tout cas
c'est intéressant de regarder quel
comment on va apprivoiser l'intelligence
artificielle est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on
s'en en parle et est-ce qu'on l'utilise
et est-ce qu'on est transparent et
est-ce qu'on utilise ses capacités pour
aller plus loin dans la réflexion c'est
ça qui va falloir maîtriser demain si
c'est pour rédiger des actes
administratifs pourquoi si c'est pour
faire un discours sur l'intérêt de la
souveraineté énergétique ou alimentaire
en France je sais pas s'il faut pas un
peu plus d'âmes humaines et dames du
territoire il va falloir qu'on mette un
peu d'humain dans tout ça de culturel
bon je crois qu'on en est au début il
faut pas qu'on s'en éloigne moi
j'entends des gens qui disent faut
l'interdire faut l'interdire non faut
pas l'interdire il faut le réglementer
il faudrait le réglementer je sais pas
tout de suite mais en tout cas il faut
beaucoup de transparence il faut
l'utiliser il faut pas rester à
l'arrière de ces technologies là c'est
jamais bon parce qu'après on se fait
imposer par par les autres de
l'extérieur donc non je pense qu'il faut
l'appréhender il faut être transparent
et il faut aller chercher le meilleur de
l'intelligence artificielle pour donner
le meilleur aux hommes donc voilà
et on va terminer sur ces belles paroles
Sébastien merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous le nouvel et sort du vrac
c'est à la Une de l'écho-républicain
aujourd'hui merci beaucoup Sébastien
Corentin d'avoir été avec nous merci
Sophie prima merci merci et on suivra
bien sûr l'examen de la proposition de
loi demain on en parlera avec Marcelo le
nez et l'agriculture peut-être qu'un
jour vous rédigerez ce rapport avec chat
GPT
si l'âme des territoires sera là-dedans
mais bon pourquoi pas on verra merci
d'avoir été notre invité ce matin